foreign
are there any other books writers
thinkers experiences that people might
be able to look to themselves that have
changed your experience of time or your
ability to slow down
I've been weirdly obsessed with time
ever since I met this guy in a monastery
in Massachusetts on my first Vagabond
trip I was like 23. this dude wherever
he is thank you whoever you are he he
just left the Navy he was and he was he
was in the contemplation room of a
monastery and I I didn't want to become
a Trappist monk but it's like the only
place where I could stay for free and I
was a dirtbag and I wanted to stay there
and this guy he was just out of the Navy
he wasn't necessarily going to become a
monk but he was really interested in
monasticism and he had this skull and
crossbones on his arm and that's where I
learned the phrase Memento Mori I had no
idea what momentum more I remember death
is the philosophical idea of remember
death and I've been thinking about it
ever since you know actually one of The
Inspirations for me as a traveler you
know for vagabonding and up to the new
book is just the idea of that life
doesn't necessarily reward you in time
my grandfather was a Kansas farmer he
worked really hard from the age 15 he
dropped out of school took over the farm
when his dad died worked his ass off and
then when he got to retirement age his
wife my grandmother got Alzheimer's
disease and he took care of her for the
rest of his life and so that was a
really heartbreaking thing when I was
young but I realized that you sort of
that time isn't just given to you in a
rational way in life you have to grab
time as as you were allowed to grab it
and so I mean there's great writing
about time is it Oliver Berkman I think
I think you've covered other people four
thousand weeks I think four thousand
weeks yeah no I've I haven't finished
that book but it's and I I always read
like 10 books at once but the philosophy
of time and the idea of time and now the
scent of time is something that I've
always sort of Obsessed about and
actually one of my favorite filmmakers
is Richard linklater who and time is
sort of one of the things he experiments
in as a filmmaker and you know I love
Before Sunrise because it's about who a
guy who meets his his true love you know
on a train in in Austria well I met my
wife the one time I wasn't traveling but
that's still a very meaningful movie to
me because they talk so much about time
in that trilogy and they talk about
journaling you know which is something I
know you talk about quite a bit but is
not done as much anymore as it was in
the 90s when that movie was first made
and just the idea that Celine that
character in Before Sunrise is talking
about coming to this city as a teenager
and writing in her journal and basically
having a conversation with herself based
upon what she wrote in that journal and
Richard linklater has some other you
know the Boyhood is about very
specifically about time and aging and
things like that but I think I I saw
Before Sunrise around the time that I
left that Monastery with the Navy guy
with the tattoo who taught me about
Memento Mori and so I've thought about
that and it's I think it's really
important to be cognizant of time and
just the idea that the moment is what we
have and there's so many ways to embrace
time but um maybe as an obsessive
traveler it's always puts me into this
thought experiment of how time is
playing out and how I'm making use of it